okay so a funny little story here I was
like I'm caught up with DC rebirth for
the most part and I'm caught up with
all-new all-different marvel at least
the titles that interest me anyway
and I was going to move on to indie
comics but I was like well me is there
anything from Marvel or DC that I
haven't read yet and I was going through
my my full list and I came across DC
bombshells and I was like that's right I
have this is my polis and I've never
read it
for me as chemists explain because of
the fact that my channel like my source
of employment is literally going over
comics I buy all the comics that come
out from Marvel and DC in terms of like
the top shelf ones and then I get a few
here and there who are sort of like
outliers that people wouldn't normally
watch or people would normally read or
something like that but I get them just
because they seem kind of cool in DC
bombshells is one of those now the funny
thing is DC bombshells I believe
originally started off as like posters
like it just started off it's like these
reimagining zuv this sort of like 1940s
you know comic book characters usually
focusing on women for the most part it
only really focused on women which is
why it's called bombshells but it was
those popular women that DC had so like
Wonder Woman Harley Quinn and so on and
it's like what would Halle Quinn looked
like if she existed in the 1940s with
the whole 1940's appearance in the whole
nine yards the posters turned into
statues and collectibles which in turn
turned into a comic book line the
statues and collectibles for DC
bombshells are stupid popular like it's
crazy how much people love those things
and mindfully so they are beautifully
designed like they look absolutely
amazing I thought about getting a few of
them here and there but I've never
really gotten around to it but the DC
bombshells line is designed to basically
be like this digital series so it's not
like injustice but it's designed to be
this series that basically focuses on
the story of the DC bombshells
characters you know these characters
that you know went from posters to
collectibles to the actual comic itself
and the first three issues are basically
called enlisted and what those do is
those basically deal with the
introductions or the origin stories of
the characters that are most likely
going to be part of the DC bombshells
line and then of course from there it
goes into a story and then it picks up
new origins as new characters are
introduced they're really just kind of
expands on us oh right now it's like
issue 96 or something crazy like that
like it's been going on for a while but
this one picks up with that one now one
thing I want to point out to you guys is
that there really is no like that man
there's no Superman at least well not in
the early days anyway the way does this
origin story is done with that woman it
kind of hints on the idea of Bruce Wayne
like in this particular instance
it really opens up with the idea of two
parents leaving zora with their son and
then somebody you know runs up and tries
to rob them and that woman jumps to the
rescue with their baseball bat and
rescues the family Batman in the
traditional sense basically all the
characters that were used to
we don't really see here instead what DC
does is actually pretty genius they
really kind of nestled this story right
into the niche of 1940s society in the
sense that when what war two is ramping
up you know world war one world war two
the homefront was basically taken care
of by women you know that's what Rosie
the Riveter came from and all those
different things the guys were fighting
over seats the guys were in the military
they were on the front lines the
invasion of Normandy and all that kind
of good stuff they were doing all that
back in the States
women were taking up manufacturing jobs
and women were taking up you know a lot
of the roles that would normally be
reserved for men because somebody had to
keep the country running and so again it
was really kind of a cool scenario but
what this does is it sort of capitalizes
on that and it says okay you know at
this moment there's no Batman
there's no Superman I mean presumably
they're off doing their own thing this
is an alternate universe story so they
may not exist at all but the very least
you know it really focuses more on the
female aspect of this now the funny
thing about Kate Kane is that there are
a lot of things that they maintain in
this alternate reality 1940s story about
her character they're really kind of
goes into the roots of her new 52 origin
because remember this came out at around
2011 or so so the idea was that if DC
was doing a line wide reboot it wouldn't
make any sense to write a story called
bombshells and then relate the
characters to their classic DC roots it
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense and
so instead we effectively get this kind
of you know new 52 origin esque sort of
situation innocence that it's not the
exact same but some of the things are
pretty similar now one of the cool
things here is that in this instance
because the fact that she'll because the
fact there's no real like Batman per se
there really isn't you know Kate Cain
being like the traditional bat woman
with the cloak in the towel and all that
kind of good stuff instead she's called
the bat woman because she wields a
baseball bat and the other cool thing is
of course she's on like the local you
know the Gotham women's softball team or
baseball team rather and that kind of
good thing you know has her own
teammates so on and so forth but she
basically tries to stop crime where she
can you know fight crime where she can
but it's really sort of sort of fun here
because in this particular situation
there's a handful of people who try to
rob the spectators why you would think
it's a good idea to rob spectators at a
baseball game with a few thousand people
watching I have no earthly clue you
think those two thousand people would
just beat the absolute crap
seven guys and the problem would be
solved but at the end of the day Cain
jumps in those are baseball you know
takes this guy out but the real meat and
potatoes of all this really comes in the
form of Maggie Sawyer now Maggie Sawyer
has a very very lengthy history she was
a John Byrne creation I believe and I
believe it was Superman number four like
the Man of Steel after crisis on
Infinite Earths so as you guys don't
know after crisis on Infinite Earths
John Byrne came along and wrote like a
six-issue miniseries called the Man of
Steel which basically detailed the new
origin of Superman after crisis on
Infinite Earths
and I believe that Maggie Sawyer was
rolled in as part of that new origin
just being a member of the metropolis PD
but over time and especially getting
into the new 52 she was more involved
with Kate Kane because of course again
Kate Kane has an alternate lifestyle and
so the idea is the two of them were
basically paired together now one of the
cool things is that in the mainline new
52 comics which is to say in the main DC
Universe Kate Kane and Maggie Sawyer
went together in so far that Maggie
story would basically try to cover up or
release to try to help Kate Kane with
their various escapades as Batwoman in
the sense that Maggie Sawyer would
provide inside information she'd let her
know about the goings-on of the of the
Gotham City Police Department or she'd
tell them you know hey here's an
investigation that we're doing or here's
a lead on a case that you're working or
ever the case may be but she would be
the police health in the same way that
Jim Gordon was the police help for
Batman Maggie Sawyer did the same thing
for bat woman the cool thing about this
though is that in this DC bombshells
landscape the two are still very much
together there's still very much a
couple which is actually good to see
because I feel like the world of that
woman plays that Kate Kane plays you
know one having an alternative lifestyle
which grants some measure of empowerment
and to purge is kind of you know being
that woman I'm glad to see that kind of
thing is maintained the interpersonal
relationships still stay the same
because it creates a measure of
familiarity right like we don't feel
like we're reading something so wholly
removed from everything that we know
that it might as well not even be called
DC Comics it can be called anything else
it's good to see that we don't have that
everything is still intact
everything is still held together you
know by the blue it is continuity reboot
so I have no idea but in terms of her
origin all really told or at least all
we really know is that she's basically
taken over Kane Enterprise she's
basically the one running the show but
the problem with this from her
perspective is that Kane Enterprises is
very much involved in the war effort now
if that makes sense because that's the
way of
during World War two one more - and you
may have heard this phrase before but
world war two is what's referred to as a
total war effort and what that means is
that all facets of American society are
part of the war effort everything goes
into it if you are a company that makes
nylon stockings when you're not making
nylon stockings anymore you're making
parachutes if you're a company that
builds cars where you're not building
cars anymore you're building tanks just
that's the the whole total war effort
that went into it some of it was
government regulated not a whole lot
most of it was hey look it's just kind
of what we have to do because it's a
literal threat to our way of life
but plus there was a lot of profiteering
a lot of money in that you know a lot of
incentives that went into it there are a
lot of politics on the back side of
World War two it's it's kind of crazy I
once read a book called the rise and
fall of the Third Reich I think is what
it was called details are rise and fall
Nazi Germany on that in and then there's
all different kinds of stuff but anyway
the fact remains with regards to Kane
enterprises the company that Kate Kane
is effectively leading it's part of the
total war effort and so what that means
is that all the resources of the company
that she runs are geared towards the war
effort they're geared towards you know
arms and armament they're gear towards
lanes and tanks and all kinds of good
stuff and so the result is that despite
the fact that the company is successful
and it's doing his job ultimately she
feels like she's not doing hers and that
really kind of goes to the crux of the
nature of superheroes right because the
great thing about DC bombshells is it
has this sort of rockstars LA noire I
don't how many of you guys played LA
noire I love that game
but it has a kind of feel between rock
stars LA noire and sucker punch and like
the Golden Age feel of superheroes all
kind of rolled into one we get the LA
noire feel just because of the era in
time in which this takes place we know
that I want la Noire I think was more in
the 1950s maybe the early nineteen in
the mid 1940s Golden Age of superheroes
was in the 1940s and we get that feel in
the sense of this is right this is wrong
there is no in-between either I'm doing
the right thing where I'm doing the
wrong thing and a lot of ways it can be
viewed as a black-and-white moral
perspective but really in terms of
superheroes it fits because there's good
guys and there's bad guys and there's no
moral ambiguity there that's one of the
things I always loved about the the
Golden Age of superheroes in terms of
how they were drawn especially drawn by
Alex Ross in terms of how their stories
we're told I'm the good guy you're the
bad guy you do bad things don't care why
you're going to jail once you get caught
and then the other half of this of
course is the sucker punch
where it focuses mostly on a femme
fatale kind of cast and so because of
that with regards to Kate Cain situation
kind of in this mode where she's like
look everybody else is fighting the war
and I'm just sitting around with a
baseball bat beating up bad guys and
calling it a day what this does is it
creates a little bit of strife between
Kate Cain and Maggie Sawyer now the
reason why this is important is because
of the fact that in the new 52 mainline
comics the struggle that came between
Kate Cain and Maggie Sawyer was by
virtue of the fact that Kate Cain was
that one and so her life as a vigilante
crime fighter in a lot of ways to create
a problems with the relationship between
herself and Maggie this is kind of a
stand-in for that as opposed to her
being a vigilante crime fighter she's a
person that has a moral imperative to
fight the bad guys presumably overseas
somewhere and so the fact that she wants
to do something better do something
greater kind of creates a little bit of
strife between her and Maggie because
Maggie kind of feels like she's left out
right like Maggie looks at the situation
and says I'm your significant other like
I should be able to provide everything
you need but at the end of the day
Maggie's not able to because Maggie
cannot enable Kate Cain to go overseas
and fight
Maggie cannot bring back the days when
when Kate Cain was an adventurer when
she was going around and going checking
all kinds of things out and touring the
world and engaging in jelly's
adventurous scenarios Maggie can't bring
that to her all Maggie can do is offer
some small measure of peace and call it
a day but that small measure of peace is
being offered here isn't really enough
and so the wish of Kate Cain comes to a
head when they kind of receive a rude
awakening with a helicopter landing on
their roof and what is up happening is
out of this helicopter steps Amanda
Waller and Amanda Waller says how would
you like to end the war so again this
really begins the process of bringing
the characters together a really kind of
a line then the next one focuses on
Wonder Woman the one after that
I believe focuses on Mara and the roster
continues to expand you know of course
as the stories begin to progress but in
any event guys if you are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and let me know
down in the comments section how you
guys feel about bombshells I love it I
think bombshells like like I sat down
and I was like well let's start reading
it before I knew it I was almost halfway
through I was thirty issues in and I was
like oh my god this story's amazing
so absolutely love bombshells but let me
know how do you guys feel about this and
yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]